okay let me take a break from the
serious stuff but this is so funny and
we need a little bit of levity these
days so maybe you'll grant me a couple
of minutes for this every once in a
while I'll do something random on the
show just to make things up mix things
up for myself mix things up for people
do a little something different with the
staff just to as a joke once at our New
York City studio the heat wasn't working
in the entire building so I wore like a
big winter coat and a hat during the
show and I don't think I ever really
explained what I was doing or why I did
that and I've got a whole bunch of
emails about it once a couple of years
ago I did an entire show with my hair
looking really odd to celebrate that we
reached 2,000 patrons on our patreon
page and it created quite a stir earlier
this week I did the show with my hair
looking odd and there really wasn't any
reason for it other than I just felt
like mixing things up our audience was
so concerned about it that I want to
show you some of the hilarious messages
I received and I love this because a lot
of people were seemed genuinely worried
about me that my disheveled hair was a
sign that the Iran thing was really
getting me down or something like that
sometimes I just do things for a
reaction because I'm curious if
something like this will take over the
comment sections and typically it does
once during a live stream I did on
YouTube I wore a sweatshirt that had a
weird shawl collar that almost looked
like a bathrobe and like 90% of the
comments on the live stream were about
my shawl collar so check out some of the
comments that I that I got about the
hair stuff Warren has a plan for
everything I wonder if she has a plan
for David's hair 100% of David's
haircuts are being paid for by no one
are you okay David unshaven disheveled
hair looking matter and matter and this
is from a guy who used to have long long
hair you're not looking well mate hope
all is well have you thought about a
break I actually just took a break I'm
feeling quite good seriously do
something with the hair at least the
fork in a light socket look is an
improvement over the usual gumbies Gumby
slant sorry to be off-topic but your
hair has a life of its own at the moment
soon it'll have its own zip code no
doubt you're making a lot of balding men
very jealous maybe the funniest this is
from a very nice lady who
watches the show with her husband I
posted this to my social media this is
my favorite hi David
lots to worry over but Terry and I are
hoping you're okay as your hair is more
disheveled each passing day so we wish
you well thank you for your opinions
warm regards from Down Under
I'm fine I appreciate the concern it's
just a joke sometimes we do things to
mix things up producer Pat was perplexed
by my hair a couple of days ago I
actually i-i've run the idea by Pat of
one day just wearing a fake mustache but
never mentioning it like never
addressing it never explaining how it
appeared one day and was gone the next
but now that I see how many people were
worried about just my hair hundreds and
hundreds of comments about it I should
probably think twice about it let me
know if you were worried about me on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me there we
will take a quick break
huge huge Friday show for you today I'm
glad you're with us